there's honestly no worse feeling than
the overwhelming crippling cringe
sensation of watching back something you
once created and thought was great when
truthfully it's actually just well print
today I'm gonna be diving deep and
watching my worst videos ever created by
myself and to make this whole process
even that much more cringe I've invited
a beautiful code who reacts and raids
these prints worthy videos with me my
beautiful fiance I'm ready for this I'm
ready for this stop I'm ready for this
[Music]
wait Annie but before you get into that
fun of me if you don't know me my name
is Dan mace and my roots lie on the edge
of the southern hemisphere and a tiny
seaside town called Scott and I'm the
owner youtuber that's from this town
that consists behind three people making
me the most subscribed Scarborough
YouTube mentor please help keep this
dream alive for me and subscribe I have
an adjacently comments or scandal lately
huggers and Ultra speed catch up with
that a lot of videos have been popping
up about me lately some good some bad
but I just want to take the time to
thank you if you have ripped me or both
me I appreciate you and thank you for
the time then the highly anticipated
take of V Tuesday intro
I finished that I think so don't but
every time I try and send it to New York
I think it gets stuck in customs so I'm
gonna try and ship this one last time
[Music]
then my ex-boss still hates me taking
really good friends then am i no longer
pottery succeed some cases videos what's
going on when I go to Croatia and
Albania Thane to this man to go shoot
some snowboarding movie and I'll come
back to that German in the middle of
March I leave back to New York and in
embark on season 2 which is what I've
been spending all my efforts and time on
planning during the space Joey boy is
still trying to catch his tail I was
letting myself go fitness-wise towards
in the last year so I've started
training
[Music]
I changed all of my gear in the office
back to Cannon why well I just I just
like cannon and in and only candy in a
flash
then I'll see if you want to see a
little bit more about my creative outlet
you should follow me on Instagram where
I post imagery there of my missions now
to get back to the video with gaps we're
gonna strap these on which ones you
choose
yo this is a conjuring list of videos
deep deep from the past this is pre
meeting all of us that's something that
I have to state you're gonna watch these
videos in detail and then you're gonna
rate them over here non bias as if you
didn't know each video you going to rate
out of 10 you're cool with that you
should I'm gonna hit ya no need to take
down notes
give me a thumbnail over there you gotta
piss like he cringing like this okay
this is the first video I ever made I
was 16 years old are you ready
[Music]
why are you laughing it's serious this
is about Jack the Ripper did you know
that is those two good cuts that's my
dad spends way too much it it's serious
[Music]
this is doc did you get it it doesn't
make sense to me because I write that
[ __ ] because that that there's gonna be
five murders know the video is
explaining why he murdered those people
it's not that hard
what is that because I do already
understand the story not at all thank
you next time that's good
this is the this one's bad chef hundred
idiot this was so soon when I was 16
this was for Brandon and Ne Win to
actually become quite famous this song
which is stopping the charts in South
Africa Ryan and Andrew Chaplin wait here
with the guys from lucky villain this is
a fish music man this is my first music
video I used to call myself
rancid pie why Hey Schatzi
I like it and I got this song the songs
Olsen there look at the music video I
keep them out to use paper at the back
this is what I thought it's the coolest
shot nice yeah see do you get the
narrative there's a Kia narrative yet I
thought this was the coolest effect what
is this
I'm in so much pain after watching that
hey you can't be bias in cages you the
judge all right let's move oh yeah I
just want to say that I'm not proud of
this okay this one's cool shoot a
playboy cop ago hey I'm down the dog
except that's when I would call myself
down that I raked it
[Music]
what that's pretty cool is this cringe
about or do you just want people to know
that you should make it go yeah that's I
can name it no this is then is look at
the thumbnail thank you no I think that
they flagged it when I put it out I love
you for what cringe is like how I used
to say hey I'm down the director doing
that's weird it seems me too you know
those people know me oh this one got
like nineteen thousand views and we knew
him when you okay this one's quite fun
[Music]
this is a McDonald's commercial that I
started hey this is all that go was
supposed to be my girlfriend but she was
like 23 inch Shack burger had these
toothpicks in and when I bent into what
I was thinking that he was going to go
into my palate ah yeah I was so nervous
like after that I decided I want to
become a film director because I didn't
want to have to act every game ya6
you couldn't need to burger property and
you weren't being a pants party but it
was cool man this has been soul
destroying oh okay seventeen
this is a 45-minute documentary this is
rancid pie again this is like this whole
intro idea I had my mom was phoning
about this TV that washed up on the
beach it were you can see me in the
reflection Daniel I used to ride the
phone by Daniel mace to sound older you
got a dirt track ah yeah there was lean
as every way look at the ticks
futuristic fatty thanks mobile and
skinny good surf back in the day
okay that's enough of that no that one
took me six months Oh what wait everyone
nowadays goes on and types into YouTube
I had a book and it didn't like
crossfade not see mixed with like
another CrossFit you never forget how I
did it I couldn't undo it serves leave
it is you know
who makes machine okay that was my
myspace profile picture and the middle
of my sweetie would have a sound check
of the play and it was been looking like
that we've done a pose as the background
I couldn't even imagine what my life
would be like without serving no I can't
even imagine what my life would be like
without serving even think I even
distorted it slightly to make sure that
was the guy I was a part of definitely
just a hardcore gang set cause no no
pride as part of my youth but I did it
[Music]
for watching my for watching Manny
thank you for watching my movie see I
used to call it movies back then I knew
it maybe you can call it that whatever
you want about it
I know but people get angry okay no one
gets to save it because it's funny and
you thank your mom thanks MA yeah I know
you have to love one of them because if
you didn't do that that you wouldn't do
that it'd be not gonna watch this gonna
be 80 and we are gonna cringe
[Music]
and that was a really funny experiment
and back in the day when I was making
those foams I had to work with what I
had camera wise and the quality wasn't
very good as well as I had to try and
recreate a lot of the scenes which is
what made it pretty cringe that's in
this day and age you are lucky because
you have unlimited access to stocks with
amazing sights like storybrooke's the
brews that story drugs sponsored this
video thank you if you don't know what
story abducts is you can click on the
link in the top of my description to
find out now if you've ever been in the
need for a quick video for b-roll After
Effects templates or motion backgrounds
there's been plenty of times it's 30
blocks is that you saved my vineyard
like in the video I explained how I
escaped from prison in Indonesia how to
recreates a lot of emotion a lot of the
tension through the use of stock footage
story blogs clips are super easy to find
and what spaces you can download as many
times as you like uh no quality to test
to see if they work in your project
first this gives you a limitless work
stream it's super affordable you get
unlimited downloads at one low cost
giving you more options to finish your
project other than that you're awesome
brute and I'll see you next week
[Music]